welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and we have a
whole host of new leaks and plot details
about all of the upcoming Marvel phase 4
movies and Disney Plus shows throughout
this video I'm gonna be going over
everything you need to know about the
news as well as what we can take from it
whilst these are leaks and should be
taken with a grain of salt there may be
some spoilers here if they turn out to
be true so if you don't want anything
potentially ruined about the upcoming
films then I highly recommend that you
turn off now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
this video now let's get into my
breakdown of the phase 4 news ok so the
phase 4 updates come directly from the
4chan TV board and cover pretty much
every upcoming project the first
announcement says that in Black Widow
Natasha's father will be played by Ray
Winstone and the movie will showcase a
lot of his relationship with the ditch
allure character Isabela Moana also
plays a new KGB recruit mentored by
David harbors red Guardian next up is
the Eternals and apparently the main
plot of the film will center around
Black Knight in Circe's relationship in
addition to this Adam Scott and Brendan
Gleeson are cast as eros and zu wrasse
from here the report goes to Schanke and
the legend of the ten rings and this
actually has quite an interesting
aesthetic to it The Legend of the ten
rings is supposedly set before n gamer
but after infinity war this is probably
between the five-year gap between the
death of danos and the Avengers
traveling through time to get the
Infinity stones the report says that
there's little to no connection to the
MCU beside the ten rings however they
may use the rising gang warfare to
explain why Hawkeye is in Asia in
endgame whilst the locations may be
different in endgame and the ten rings
the movie has the potential to set up
the gangs that we see the character
fighting in that film and I think it
makes sense to explain why Hawkeye felt
the need to go vigilante on a worldwide
scale
Steven Yen Kelly Marie Tran BD Wong
Jamie Chung and Donnie Yen are also
being offered roles in the production
dr. strange in the multiverse of madness
features the return of the ancient one
and Quicksilver this is interesting as
there were rumors that Scala which could
be the madness in the title and we have
heard leaks that the film is about her
tearing across the multiverse this could
potentially allow her to pull a version
of a brother out of an alternate
timeline and whilst we don't have word
on how she gets vision back either if
she does pull him out of an alternate
reality then you could see how in her
mind this is a one-size-fits-all
solution to her problems this has the
potential to be what's causing her
madness as she could try and fix all of
the issues in her life and right the
wrongs at the expense of other universes
David Tennant also apparently is the
studio's number-one choice for the
villain nightmare next up it says
spider-man 3 was planned to come out in
July 2021
before the Sony Marvel deal fell apart
this comes in the wake of Sony saying
that the door is now closed on the deal
and it looks like they will be going
forward with the character Thor love and
thunder also takes place 95% in space
and it will also see the return of Peter
Dinklage as Eitri Chris Pratt has a
small appearances quill and Taika
Waititi once Ryan Gosling and fin wolf
odd for roles in the film I definitely
think that Pratt will feature in the
movie as will the rest of the guardians
especially with how endgame finished up
so this seems quite likely next up the
report said that the Fantastic Four film
is the February 2022 release we did get
an announcement of black panther with
two other unannounced films so it looks
like this makes sense the x-men reboot
is also apparently a high priority for
Disney with them wanting it to be
released no later than 2023 black
panther 2 will be about Namor taking
over Wakanda and Michael B Jordan has a
minor role as kill manga possibly
featuring on the spiritual plane as he
was the king of Wakanda even if the rain
was short-lived
guardians of the galaxy 3 is set to be
released July 2022 Luka still at deca
Montgomery and Zac Efron all met with
James Gunn about playing Adam warlock
and Mark Hamill is in the film as the
High Evolutionary Blade and Captain
Marvel 2 are set for 2023 and lastly
Kevin Feige has met with you
Gregor Milly Bobby Braun Keanu Reeves
Hamish Patel Colin Farrell Jessica
Chastain and Henry Cavill for future MC
roles and that's all of the news updates
that we have whilst we will have to wait
for trailers and the movies themselves
to see if they're true they all seem
quite likely and tie in with a lot of
the leaks that we've had so far I'm
actually really excited for shang-chi
and Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness which from these leaks sounds
really exciting a thing that they have
the potential to be some of the most
unique superhero films ever made and I'm
massively hyped for them now obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on these
updates and if they make you more
excited for the films or not comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video and want something else to
watch them make sure you check out my
breakdown of penny wise from Stephen
King's it which will be linked at the
end I go over the full characters
origins history and fate in it chapter 2
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
come talk to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books then you can
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully i see you over there after
this also just wanna let you know that
we're giving away a free copy of John
wick 3 and blu-ray and all you have to
do to be in with a chance of winning is
to like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the face for updates in the
comments section below the winner will
be chosen at random on September the
10th and the blu-ray will be shipped out
from then to ever get surprised so best
of luck to everyone who takes part this
is a channel for people who are super
into superheroes so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you